partner on the lines Carter sandlak
and John mcis of the referees here's
Benson just inside the line hit
by Greenway opening up some ice
here as the Sabers come back on the
counter Greenway scores bang bang
Greenway a hit in the goal to hit in Buffalo
any day and it's one nothing Savers got son
and then he just get on his horse get up
the ice and right there the Quick Pass he
had nothing shot to the net this is perfect
cliping just feeds it to him he gets it he's
got nothing so he fires to the net catches s
on up in the opening period Lea stall at their
own Blue Line a little biten a couple
of looks as he plays that puck on the
far side and Matthews right it well Austin
Matthews spins that one along the goal line
and in off of Levi just about a foot or two
above the goal line and this game is tied at
one and it's just down in the corner and
Matthews one of those guys you always
got to be aware he's about 4T above
the line there just turns and fires
and let's see if it goes off anything
coming through there it comes oh just
beats a p but you see where darene is
right in front of Levi just kind of in
[Applause] that he's back in the Zone leren
Morgan Riley top of the far Circle there's
the shot M and that one's off the bar and in it's
a power play marker for the leash to lead at two
to one with 721 to go in the opening period here
he is just the feed by Morgan Riley comes across
there's really nothing there he takes the quick
shot he heard it off the post can you see this
coming through yeah he's able to see that maxus
beats him on the far side banging in as you said
a power play marker that's calmly possessing that
puck in letting the Sabers regroup here and get a
breakout started up to Center nice feed through
on the followup great pass try to go back across
empty n [Applause] scores Owen power stays with
the play and the Sabers have tied the game of
two go here tonight he he Middle St with
a nice little move there he makes the play
Then he keeps driving to the net gets everybody
backed off by time Owen power here's the quick
pass across to Benson and I think he looked
to go back to Middle stat gender makes the
save with the left pad and just leaves it l
right there for Owen power to step in goes
from forehand to backhand gets the clear
Lane puts it in the heart of the net and
TI Long Reach in Stick check by Marner that
time on Thompson they have a word two as they
escape by one another Sab dump it right back in
Tuck takes it away in front Skinner [Applause]
SC welcome back Jeff Skinner giving the
Sabers a three to2 lead with 409 to go in
the first there Alex tuck doing a nice job
he just pulls that one off the wall into
his feet and bang he takes the quick look
sner you see the angle he's on he doesn't
have much there but he gets it just gets that
body turned just enough and take a quick shot
right over the left shoulder s off right
there and that's the third goal it's a big
one face off to the right of the
Maple Leafs net middle stat trying
to go forward with it Dalene will keep it in paage
Thompson pressured immediately that
time by mccab Dalene walks in fire
scores R SM darene with a delicious finish
on the power play and the Sabers lead at 4-2
Bo here this Puck does not go down bad
play there and the Sabers recover takes
Thompson doing some nice work on the side
he's just going to set up his body right
there s enough doesn't even move watch this
he doesn't see it coming through he has no
idea and I think that's tuck who gets across
the front yes it is and it kind of took his
vision away Skinner to the goal line to doing
Thompson one timer and seloff has seen that
show made the save a two-on one for the leaf
so short-handed neander slid it across they
score Yar cro and nander finish the two-on-one
shorthanded for the M police and it's a 43 Buffalo
lead k y is going to be the guy that finished
but it's Save Right There by a bigot shot by
Tage Thompson turns into the two-on-one William
neander makes this pass across and Yar makes no
mistake here he almost thought neander was coming
in getting into that lane to take the shot himself
and as soon as darene drops down here the pass
comes across Morgan Riley halfway now back up top
Matthews for neander who came from the goal line
High into the zone and Skinner with the good read
as well intercepts gets to Center finds Alex tuck
for Tage Thompson left side shot [Applause] scor
from the top of the circle TNT for Buffalo
and it's 53 Sabers 1138 to go in the second
period and you see the Savers there just doing a
nice job taking that middle of the ice away in the
defensive Zone Skinner is going to work his way
up Tuck over to Thompson and Thompson Wast no time
he's got Tuck going to the net he's going to fire
the puck and watching the way chance now playing
tonight you should fire the puck every time you
get down the ice it goes off as Sabers would
love to get that short-handed goal back here's
DOI passes it onto the wing and yarn crook off
the left boards back to DOI took that one away
and now a breakway here for the Savers KY poso
scores shorty for shorty and the Savers are
up 6 to3 kyoso seventh just nice read as he
said a lot of pressure on the top side here
of the penalty kill putting pressure on the
D not allowing things to get set up and
get Advance into the zone and KY aosa
what a shot he beats Martin Jones over the
glove Martin Jones didn't even move that
glove and he feeds a short pass up the
middle PKA looking to gain the line and
he does for cousins rips shot trying to go
high on Jones clion throws it behind the net
pkus got Quinn in front holds it Quinn
[Applause] scor Welcome Back The Mighty
[Music] Quinn and just watch this here's Quinn
right there in the bottom of your screen some
good work along the wall they're keeping this
Puck Alive by Conor clipon once again and JJ
PKA what a pass he dusted off a couple times over
there he's got his head up the whole time right
across the top of the blue paint great right past
Jake mccab stick and there's Jack Quinn right on
the door the next challenge will be the next one
yeah the next two actually got Rangers and Bruins
coming up here so hope they get themselves rolling
Skinner scor speak of rolling they are rolling
rolling rolling 83 now with skinners second of
the game he better get 10 CH Thompson nice job
down low here but this line they just they have
so much chemistry to together Eric Johnson at the
near Point pass across ran Johnson able to keep
it in kylo poso unable to knock it down he down
[Applause]
scores here and the receivers doing a great
job being all over the puck they got numbers
on the puck all the time they willingness
to throw the puck to the [Applause] net
and the Toronto gending has not been
good for them tonight but the Sabers
are totally taking advant it and let the
crowd take this one from here for the next
five